there's some new political fallout for
Hillary Clinton Fox News now confirming
that Clinton and the DNC paid for the
research that led to that infamous
Russian dossier as you may recall that
dossier tried to paint tied the
President to Moscow here's what we know
a lawyer representing the Clinton camp
retained a firm called fusion GPS to
compile opposition research the firm
hired dossier author Christopher Steele
a former British spy earlier President
Trump reacted to the revelations I think
it's very sad what they've done with
this fake dossier was made up I
understand they paid a tremendous amount
of money and Hillary Clinton always
denied it the Democrats always denied it
and now only because it's going to come
out in a case they said yes they did it
okay so one I have to ask you when I
first saw the news last night I thought
didn't we already know this and then I
realized that we actually didn't know
the one piece which is that the Clinton
campaign itself and the DNC had actually
helped pay for it it wasn't a third
party no I think we knew that I think we
knew that the Clintons had been involved
in Clinton campaign or somebody
representing Clinton's campaign but
Devin Nunez who was I guess still has
subpoena power in the Congress although
he said he was recusing himself when
stepping back from leadership of the
House investigation then said you know
really want to know who among the
Clinton folks was paying for this and
they found out so they went to they've
subpoenaed Fuzion GPS for bank records
that forced some people on the
Democratic Clinton side then to say you
know what forget it fusion you don't
have to abide by the confidentiality
agreement we'll tell our names yep and
it turned out it was mark Elias or Elias
who was a lawyer who's you know an
election lawyer for the Clinton campaign
but I'm kind of stunned at Devon Nunez
who was you know had to recuse himself
because he was putting out classified
information at the behest of the 20
I would step back into it and so this is
distraction diversion again at the
behest of mr. Devin newness and the
Republicans from the fact that there's a
serious investigation going on into
Donald Trump's relationship with the
Russian so Brian Fallon who was the
spokesperson for the Clinton campaign
Jesse yes he was asked about this I mean
he denied any acknowledgement that there
was some sort of lie that happened here
but he also said if I had gotten handed
it less fault I would have had no
problem passing it along but isn't that
exactly what Donald Trump jr. was saying
about his meeting with that was
basically like well doesn't everybody do
it and you know people suggestible maybe
not double standard when it came to the
Don jr. meeting at Trump Tower you had a
Russian woman that came to them and said
hey I might have something on the
Clintons he said Oh what do you have and
she had nothing and the meeting ended
and no money change hands here in this
case the Clintons actively sought dirt
on Donald Trump paid for it and then
lied about it but when the Clintons do
it it's called opposition research when
Trump didn't do it
it's called collusion and it's funny
that Juan likes to talk about diversion
the story is not about Nunez this is
that was a diversion and the fact that
it was a nice try one and you know I'd
do the same thing the Clintons they said
for a year that they had nothing to do
with the dossier when it turns out they
sought it and paid for it so what the
Democrats go back on the record for
second word didn't Republicans wasn't it
that Republicans first page fusion GPS
to do opposition research on Trump yeah
but Democrats step up and then steal
gets hired by fusion and then suddenly
you say that's the equivalent of what
took place at Trump Tower which with
junior knows it's actually less
according to your stats I see because
change tends when I see the diamond
junior went right to the FBI in the way
fusion went to the FBI and said hey
we've got a problem actually I think the
FBI came to steel and tried to pay
further
and then they pled the fifth Greg so
this is just more information leading
into Robert molars investigates well it
was I'm trying to make sense of this but
they sort of didn't they serve a lump
Tower because of the information that
was in the dossier which Hilary's people
paid for and then later the FBI gets
involved in this and that's the other
piece or it's about the epic the FBI
considered paying this guy Steele some
more money to keep going but then
decided not to that's also weird because
they almost were about to use our
taxpayer money to unseat a president
which is also weird I love the fact that
for the longest time Hillary has been
blaming you know her loss on Russian
collusion and there's that old line I
remember from sleepaway camp whoever
smelt it dealt it you look at this you
look at this they commissioned this
dossier which led to a trump
investigation which now leads us back to
Hillary which she's the initial and
primary collude or I mean I call that
Chiron II it's a mixture of karma and
irony and I feel but you know I think
Trump in a way that's every reason to be
kind of angry over this because people
have been mocking the tweets about this
and he turns out he's right and she I
don't know I think I'd hate to be the
Democratic Party right now Hillary
Clinton it's like the crack house on the
block that lowers all the property
values it's time for the Clintons to go
away because they just can't seem to
shake this but it would be smart I think
Kimberly if just from a political
standpoint it's smart for the
Republicans or try to keep her very much
in the picture right absolutely there
they keep going on the book tour go
everywhere so people can ask you
questions about this and this is sad
because this is like the political
boomerang on the Democrats they thought
they had it in spades against President
Trump against his administration is
transition team and instead the whole
story has come back on them I grouped
Jesse the Democrats thought they had
this I had they put all these
allegations in sort of the mainstream
media against President Trump none of it
stood up there was no factual basis
president Trump goes Twitter tastic
everybody freaks out and turns out that
he was right and the one who is the
culprit here is the one with the name
that starts with C well it's not I would
say that but nobody knows what all of
Muller's investigation will be
and the whole piece about mana fort and
Flynn wasn't necessarily part of this
dossier thing so there are lots of
different things here and I think
there's a possibility Greg that this
could be a strategic leak somewhere to
get Republicans to say look how
legitimate the Robert Miller
investigation is now because now it's
spread to Democrats so that returning
legitimacy to something that they were
trying trying to discredit she should
have spent less time on the dossier and
more time in deerfield she's you
remember she's been blaming Russia for
her loss and in it in a way she's right
because she relied on a lurid dossier
rather than going to Wisconsin if she
had not counted on her gender and this
dossier and decided to do the legwork in
Wisconsin you know what's funny from
that she would have one right and then
the big point is none of this would have
come out had she won we never would have
known about all this disgusting nobody
would a crap that's going on but now the
Trump won we get the investigation and
now we know what's going on behind the
scenes Thank You Donald Trump for
winning and we had one other thing about
President Trump has he talked about the
something else the story we've been
talking about the uranium one deal he
talked about that at the press
conferences listen last week you thought
that the uranium sale to Russia was one
of the big stories of the decade three
congressional committees are now looking
at that we haven't heard you comment on
it since those investigations for launch
well I think the uranium sale to Russia
and the way it was done so underhanded
with tremendous amounts of money being
passed I actually think that's Watergate
modern age or anything of that line
Jesse well I see him smirking when he
called it Watergate because everybody
does that and we all had gate next to
something that is scandalous Hillary
took a hundred and forty five million
dollars from Russians
I think Podesta's firms took about
thirty million dollars from Russians the
Trump team took zero dollars from
Russians and the Podesta firm was
actually paid to help lobby the State
Department under Hillary Clinton for
uranium one so it's all can
affected and we know that they were
concerned about this because the
WikiLeaks emails show that MOOC and
falen were very worried when the story
broke because it was going to start
boomeranging them now people say do we
need a special counsel on this we're
gonna have to go special counsel crazy
if you're going to go to one let's just
throw it all and then we'll wait eight
years and then it'll finally get
frog-marched you know you know Greg said
earlier it's hard to follow all this but
you know the problem Greg smoked false
fronts and all of this I mean you would
never know that the Republican Party is
falling apart in America at this moment
if you're right that flake for that book
tour look I love the fact that this high
horse that Hillary and the Democrats
have been on that horse has been taken
out into the woods and shot because they
can oh it's embedded for an analogy okay
it's not really a real horse so no
writing about that the point is they've
been pointing fingers about all this
stuff and the finger is back at them and
by the way there is a parallel there is
a parallel to Watergate with this
dossier Nixon had the election in the
bag but they couldn't resist doing those
silly little spy games right they did it
anyway they couldn't resist
in this sense at the time that they were
paying for this dossier the New York
Times had her chances like at 97% oh
yeah and so why did she do it because
she thought she could get away with it
that's her education she is so cynical
she thought yeah why not what let's pay
for it even though she kind of had it in
the back well they're used to doing this
is how they operates if somebody came up
with this little scheme in the back of
the Scooby van with a Scooby Snacks and
Hillary was like this sounds like a
terrific idea let's make sure that I'm
gonna win nobody not even
Devon Nunez says that Hillary Clinton
was directing this nobody says even
nobody says that mark Elias was
directing steal nobody says these things
has been verified the most lewd and
lured part has not been confirmed but
the reason the FBI was thinking of
paying steal was because they thought
hey this guy's steal was already on that
was a payroll no but also I think the
FBI if I refine people can correct me
but I'm pretty sure Comey and became I
guess had him on the payroll and they
were using this guy and they were
planning on using him even after the
alleged abused them for something else
but it was fusion that hired him after
Elias came on as as a backer for effect
financier for those and the key
difference between the Republicans and
Republicans hired
GPS it was to look at the Republican
adversary was wanted to look at his
businesses it had nothing to do with the
dossier the dasya came into the picture
the dirty tricks and the lurid stuff
came with Hillary infusion came together
and said let's get this dossier so it's
important to know that was worth
anything either and know that was
verified and another thing